in good shape your health magazine on DW
featuring an interview with a different
expert every week let me welcome an
expert on trauma today with me in studio
is dr. Engel Schaefer is psychiatry
stand psychotherapist who head trauma or
patient unit at the University of
Hamburg hello welcome to in good shape
you're treating refugees with trauma so
how likely is it that they will benefit
from treatment but of course depends on
the individual situation a person has
but what can be said is that we do have
evidence-based treatments that can help
people and we can also use them in
refugee populations and I imagined that
is very very difficult because they
don't speak our language they don't
speak German usually they speak
different languages of the world
sometimes English as a foreign language
so do you treat them in English or how
do you do this no we usually have to
have interpreters to help us which of
course makes the therapy a bit more
complicated and more difficult to
organize but that's the way we have to
do it ok so we relate to talk about some
different therapy techniques but first
this question if you treat a trauma will
there always be traces in the brain or
can a trauma be completely healed yeah
that's what survivors often ask we'll
get rid of that will will it disappear
and what we have to tell them is that of
course it will be a part of your history
a part of your biography but we can try
to help you to to live better and to
lose at least some and maybe all of the
symptoms you have at the moment but your
hope is that they will be able to lead a
normal life after the therapy that's the
aim but it's also important to tell
people that it can be that some things
will still persist but we try of course
to help them to to get healthy again so
one method in therapy is talking about
the traumatic event is it very very
difficult for traumatized patients to
even speak about it or are they
speechless there are several reasons for
that can be difficult one is that the
the nature of the traumatic memory can
be that they don't even have XS and the
words for it the other thing is that
people often are ashamed about the
things that happened there's also a
cultural aspect to that that it can be
difficult to talk about many things so
speechlessness can be an issue and we
have to to look in the therapy that we
find ways to come over that right so
drama happens inside the brain and how
they the people have used about
themselves and views about other people
in the world so so what usually happens
inside the brain I mean on a
psychological level what you just said
it's the ways they look on themselves
and on others they are ashamed they feel
guilty that they survived maybe even
they feel that after torture for
instance that it they will not be a part
of the normal society anymore and at the
same time there can be a persistent idea
of threat even in save situations and
taken together best that can lead to
social withdrawal and can make a bad
situation that daily lives our viewer
Esteban Mario wants to know and if
having a drama is a disease if it's it's
always like post-traumatic stress
disorder or if having a trauma can't
perhaps if no disease at all the first
thing that's important is to separate
the event from the consequences and the
traumatic event itself is not a disease
and there are many people that can come
over such events and in fact are
resilient to them but there is a
spectrum of consequences that can follow
one is PTSD post-traumatic stress
disorder but also others like depression
anxiety substance abuse so so it's not
automatically the case that people
suffer from those consequences but it
will be a certain part I find it really
really amazing that eye movements can
have such an effect on our psyche and or
mental capacities so so what's your
experiences with emdr I personally have
good experiences with it I also use it
in treatment but it's important to say
that as you said we don't know how it
works yet and there are also other
treatments I mean the most important
thing is to focus on the traumatic event
and there are different ways to do that
in dr is a good way prolonged exposure
which is one technique of cognitive
behavioral therapy is another good way
to do that and they have both very
effective so you can choose between the
therapies it's not always emdr exactly
for patients on the knowledge of the
therapist and also the preference of the
patient but how long with emdr does the
effect lasts is it is it healing the
patient it can be there's a large
proportion of patients that can really
get healed with it a meta-analysis has
shown that it's about sixty to seventy
percent of patients who complete such a
therapy but of course the other cases
where it can be more difficult also one
viewer from Vietnam gran Lu wants to
know if they are pills to treat trauma
yeah what what role does medication play
medication can be used but it's not
really the solution we know that
psychotherapy needs to be done if people
really have PTSD but there are some
pills antidepressants for instance that
can support the healing process so
they're not really working with the
trauma itself they're more working with
the symptoms that accompany the trauma
exactly ok that's every traumatic
experience need therapy say as a
prophylactic no of course not it's
important for people to know where they
can turn to if they have had a very
severe event and they don't feel good
and in most cases it will be watchful
waiting so for a couple of weeks it's
completely normal to have symptoms after
such an event but if they endure or they
get worse it's important really to see
cancer in most cases you you wouldn't
need em therapy at all you've got just
the normal resilience and you wait and
see what happens and it's normal that
you feel stressed out and traumatized
after this kind of thing so um how can
friends and relatives help chama climate
has patients in my office sometimes and
patients with trauma and their relatives
come and say can we talk with him about
the trauma or would we do some harm yeah
that's an important point relatives are
often insecure how they can behave and I
think the most important thing is to
support both sides the survivor and the
family and to find out what really helps
the survivor and to make the family
competent in the way they deal with him
or her and it can be talking and at
times maybe it's just leaving him or her
alone important thing is to learn what
works so if you think you're in need for
professional help who should you go to
ya in most regions it will be the GP the
primary care system what also is a good
way is the internet there are a couple
of good apps that can be downloaded
there's a PTSD coach for example its
name of the app that's the name of the
error so self-help can also be away
great but recife thanks so much for
being with us in good shape today and
clairmont